[Música]
ah eu queria contar uma história que eu
passei a minha infância na fazenda
meus pais tinham uma fazenda de cavalos
e eu podia ficar perto deles sempre foi
muito prazeroso pra mim está na fazenda
e estar com os cavalos
então o que eu vou contar os cavalos
agora faz muito sentido pra mim
muitas vezes eu saía pra cá valga
acordava cedo com 56 anos minha mãe me
contou e eu voltava à noite e ela falava
mas onde estava trabalhando
então pra mim essa história que vou
contar faz sentido a dor uma tradicional
era durma feita através da surra de
bater e de submeter o cavalo
eu vi um ted talks eu não sei se a maria
dalva está aqui hoje você me inspirou
profundamente
ela fala da doma racional que é uma de
uma feita através da parceria e do afeto
e da conquista de confiança entre o
cavalo e cavaleiro
ela fala uma frase na palestra dela que
é com a intenção de domar cavalos
eu tomei a mim mesmo será que por mágica
que ela conseguiu domar a si mesma para
domar os cavalos
eu vou apresentar agora mágica que ela
fez ou que a imagem que nós vamos fazer
com nossos filhos não há mágica
a mágica está em praticar em cuidar de
nós mesmos e nos educar e treinar as
nossas emoções porque a partir de nós a
partir do nosso cuidado a gente pode
cuidar dos nossos filhos como começar
eu quero falar de três pontos da
metodologia um primeiro passo é aprender
a ser firme e gentil ao mesmo tempo com
os nossos filhos não é fácil
o segundo passo quais ferramentas de
comunicação que nós temos para conseguir
ser firme e gentil
nos momentos críticos e o terceiro é
quando nada disso der certo o que eu
faço é eu gosto de pensar que se refiram
gente ao mesmo tempo é como se nós
fôssemos um técnico
o técnico tem um conhecimento e ele quer
passar esse conhecimento por um aprendiz
num cavalo uma criança por um esportista
além de saber o conhecimento ele sabe
como passar esse conhecimento
ele tem uma comunicação ele se comunica
de forma adequada com a linguagem
adequada para cada tipo de aprendiz
uma criança de três anos é diferente de
uma criança de 10 anos ea nossa
comunicação tem que ser diferente
eu tô vendo tem muitos bebezinhos aqui
uma comunicação de 0 anos é diferente de
dez anos
o técnico faz uma comunicação clara ele
diz exatamente o que ele quer a sua
passo
se eu pegar minha filha de três anos a
sua mãe de gêmeas
luísa antónio que tem três anos se eu
pegar minha filha e fala para ela vamos
guardar os brinquedos
ela se tiver vontade
ela vai levantar e vai guardar os
brinquedos porque eu falei claramente o
que eu quero agora se eu digo a mesma
coisa
não deixe os seus brinquedos aí eu não
estou dando uma menina de três anos o
que ela deve fazer o que é muito
diferente
ela não tem isso pronto dentro dela
muitas vezes um menino de 12 anos que já
deveria ter pronto isso dentro de si não
tem e continua deixando a toalha molhada
em cima da cama e isso pode ser um
conflito em casa então a comunicação
clara nesse momento como eu diria para o
enteado de 13 anos johan coloque a sua
toalha molhada no banheiro não reativa
eu vou contar uma história de quando eu
tinha nove anos eu fiz acho olímpica dos
9 aos 14
eu tinha um técnico que eu gostava muito
dele e ele pensando hoje ele era firme e
gentil comigo
ginástica olímpica não era um esporte
fácil pra mim era muito demandante em um
desafio
tinham muitas exercícios que eu tinha
muito medo de fazer e ele dizia faça de
tal maneira que eu praticava eu errava
ele repetia eu praticava eu errava
ele repetia eu praticava eu errava e
repeti isso era muitas vezes e eu nunca
senti ele irritado comigo porque eu
errei
do mesmo jeito que a gente fica irritado
quando a toalha em cima da cama ou
quando os brinquedos estão todos
espalhados como é tentar acertar esse
olhar se conscientiza a gente pode ter
um olhar firme e gentil sim não é fácil
na depois de cem vezes você fala mas eu
garanto que é mais produtivo e mais
eficiente do que eu gritar da porta do
quarto de hora do jantar e saio e vou
pra mesa
dez minutos depois eu vou te falar hora
do jantar
ensaio de novo e quando volta já grito
hora do jantar já falei como a gente
poderia ser mais claro e mais eficientes
em se expressar porque isso me estressa
tem que falar cinco vezes
eu escuto várias mães dizendo a mesma
coisa você vai até a pessoa você
comunica de outra forma
lembrar eu vou falar das ferramentas que
a gente tem mais
lembrar que você pode chegar perto dessa
pessoa toca por essa pessoa é uma
criança
estamos falando de crianças e outra no
ipad o telefone está envolvido eu falei
três vezes na porta eu gritei você chega
põe a mão no ombro e fala à hora do
jantar
aí você pode ficar brava depois porque
ele não atendeu
então a voz a gente é uma das
ferramentas e avós a gente pode falar
alto baixo surratt a gente tem que
lembrar que o silêncio pode comunicar
muita coisa
a maneira que a gente fala é a maneira
que a gente escuta hoje mais o que falar
é com a voz que a gente tem que colocar
porque a gente pode falar de muitas
maneiras grave ou agudo
isso é uma nuance junto com o corpo ea
alma uma dança aí como balé da da
marinha dá aula de como chegar como
acertar essa entrada com essa criança
mais do que saber a maneira eu queria
deixar com vocês hoje que vocês tomar
consciência de qual é o tom grave ou
agudo ou a voz do seu filho que te
irrita
eu sei o que me irrita nomeado há há há
isso vai me deixando nervosa então eu
tenho tentado evitar de ficar nervosa
cerveja que eu tô falando de mim né e
não da criança e como eu posso comunicar
para ela que ela está incomodando porque
isso daqui a pouco essa grito eu vou até
a a acer que iria me abaixo
e falo você está mediando estava
incomodando
vamos tentar mudar o timbre está me
incomodando muito
às vezes dá certo mas com meu filho que
ele ia muito eu digo vamos ser mais
firme
vamos colocar uma voz de capitão américa
traz a voz da perna e do hulk brinco de
outra forma mas eu não quero mais ouvir
é semeado e gritar com eles de três anos
ou até dos 10 e falar
chega de gritar para debilitar bom essa
é a máxima nessa é adoro adoro quando
você fala para de gritar o seu filho
gritando é sensacional mas como é tomar
consciência para chegar perto do seu
filho gritando e você falar chega está
muito alto está doendo meu ouvido para
não falar baixo
button não é uma vez no do tom
vamos fazer uma voz de princesa inventar
coisas porque eu não quero mais ouvir
aquele barulho
não sei se dá pra dizer que eu mudei o
foco eu que não quero ouvir eu não quero
ser sá
então como eu vou comunicar por aqui no
pará
o olhar vamos lembrar que olhar pode
acolher é um incómodo que eu acho que o
técnico faz isso ele acolhe não
conseguir fazer né num exercício que não
consigo fazer a gente não tem essa gente
se perde isso de achar que é tão difícil
para uma criança aguarda o brinquedo se
toda noite eu falo para ela que eu tenho
que guardar de brinquedo mas a gente
pode ter um olhar melhor e acolher com o
olhar também acolher quer dizer não eu
fico firme gentil nesse olhar o toque e
o corpo
o nosso corpo é maior do que das
crianças que a gente está falando
vamos aproveitar porque pode ficar desse
tamanho seu filho e de carregar no colo
então nesse momento você chega perto
você usa o braço você abraça eu posso
falar brava segurando com um toque mas
gentil né eu posso a criança que corre
pela casa inteira eu posso chegar perto
e segurar e falar na hora do almoço
fora isso as palavras a palavra que eu
uso pode ser suave pode ser agressiva
pode ser vaga
vamos almoçar eu digo pra minha filha
vamos almoçar de três anos que está
brincando
não eu não eu perguntei então eu digo
firme na hora do almoço
eu não quero em acontece na minha casa
não pense que a minha casa é dizem mas
eu tenho isso na cabeça o tempo todo
como eu posso me comunicar
daqui eu não estresse adianta nada
gritava vamos você já falei luisa vamos
não adianta mais fácil chegar perto dela
e segurar porque ela pequena uso meu
corpo e eu levo ela pra mostrar bom
então tá ok né
já dá certo afirmou gentil ao mesmo
tempo é fácil
aprenderam e vamos fazer isso gente já
tem voz olhar
a atual direção muda o seu olhar e é e
está fácil
vamos falar a verdade não dá pra ser
firmes gentil ao mesmo tempo e o tempo
todo a gente sai de uma válvula de
escape a gente precisa é entender que a
gente está num como técnico eu penso eu
entro em casa eu vim aqui agora eu vim
aqui eu vestir um uma persona eu estou
aqui
palestrando para vocês depois vem de
casa quando eu entro em casa eu visto o
boné da mãe
então não acho que aquilo está
acontecendo e eu não tenho uma função eu
tenho uma função mas não dá pra fazer o
mesmo tempo
então antes de a gente fazer isso porque
dá vontade de fazer isso se retira se o
evento tada dramático ou até você daria
conta no outro dia em outro momento mas
você não está bem você se retira ser
respira no mínimo vai até o banheiro
se tiver alguém em casa você chama e
pede pra ajudar
como você se restabelecer do seu
banheiro você volta com outra energia
porque você já ouviu aqui hoje que é
tudo muito fácil eu falei então vocês
vão voltar com aquela energia firme e
gentil ao mesmo tempo para a criança que
você tá com vontade de pegar na parede
é lógico que não vai dar certo todas as
vezes e é lógico e vai falhar ea gente
vai gritar eu já fiz para de gritar eu
já fiz e ainda faço às vezes mas na hora
que eu faço eu falo não algo está errado
isso não dá fazer e eu vou para trás e
eu chamo ajuda ou eu vou ao banheiro
respiro
e volto com outra energia que a ação a
cena pode está acontecendo a mesma mas
eu tô contra energia
então voltamos mas em ach alguém ache
sua rede de ajuda faça uma comunidade de
ajuda chame a mãe o papagaio periquito
jacaré quem se puder amiga que tem filho
também onde ela fica com seu filho podia
ser feita com o outro
a barra quem puder a pé são ajuda não dá
pra ser uma boa mãe sem ajuda
e aqui eu queria deixar vocês sou eu com
a luísa que antônio mt três dias 14
porque não estão na maternidade e eu
realmente acredito que a gente cuidar da
gente a gente pode cuidar melhor nossos
filhos
[Aplausos]